[Music]
we're not strong
we're quick here we're kind of even even
so if he pushes straight back
not with your whole body walk backwards
you see I don't have a good basement the
idea is to go behind you lift you're hot
off and he's actually starting to go
behind you
yes you do have the cross lateral chat
what the energy should be rotating
behind okay let's add the same thing on
ten
[Music]
so I can turn
not here not here here my Center in Rome
okay so you can't do your team on like
to me it looks like your Aikido culture
starts taking precedence rather than
your our Aikido q1 being either
cultivation tools or tactical analysis
or just some kind okay so what's that
mean okay so I'm gonna do I'm gonna do
this maneuver and it looks like I got in
this eighth place okay but if we watch
his elbow you see there's there's no
cross my little check on this arm boom
and I don't have any concept at all I
got a champ that arm we're here right
I'm gonna check that arm and get that
shoulder on the other side there's no
awareness of that you're all you looks
like either even like you know what I
think so when you have a simple journal
poem you have to understand that I can
push this elbow in the way and get the
cross model arm on the other side of
this body to give me the split-second I
need to respond okay so when I'm coming
here same same thing if I go like this
maybe you get it but you don't have the
height yet so he goes to kick and you
can kick you don't have the drop you
guys
same thing when I'm here I understand
that I can check his head out so that he
can't kick right I want to count those
constant so I don't want a ball like
this this is like oh I guess magical and
I just do a movement know what you're
doing - same thing with placement so I
want to fight not from the back of him I
want to always understand that I always
want him you have to turn towards me do
you understand that does that's going to
give me the advantage she turns that me
a movement I can get oh I wanted to be
looking for me I'm in front we're all on
this side so I want to be in fact him I
want him to have to look for me I want
him to have to turn into me but I also
want to be somewhere ahead of him on
that spiral so we're not going to be in
terms of time in this kind of
relationship like it's a ball yes but I
am on the other side of some sort of
curve but it's because it's a spiral
well I'm ahead of him okay so when I do
what I'm doing this to new work I'm
going to be ahead of him every single
time so we're both turning but I'm
turning first right and then he's going
this way so I can go this way
same thing here whoa
no he's going that way so I can go this
way now whoa here Oh
[Music]
blue in Mic Check throwing them the
other way turn elbow in height check
wrong the other way check Rome the other
way
so he's going that way turn Rock Mic
Check Cross logical check roll the other
way Turner with him
[Music]
his body on the throw it's this same
angle so I have the back diagonal right
remember we had that front to hang no um
and we push over well now we have the
back diagonal and we're pushing over
he's not supposed to turn and go this
way so he come his energy comes in his
energy comes in it starts to turn and
he's in that position and then I'm very
much UDV not yet do you guys understand
so when you're doing this technique if I
don't have them turn and I'm going like
this don't do anything for me please and
just there you see and you have a hard
luck here but he has a rear naked and
you're gonna let go okay
so again you know he goes like this and
I don't go in here like this for this
arm lock here no he's gonna have that
right and you'll break my posture won't
open them you'll always fight from this
back corner this back corner
[Music]
there you isolate right dislike he's
down down mountain right I'm not pushing
over here I'm isolating this arm
remember I feel like the arm same thing
so I am going to be here not here this
corner here this corner here so I do two
technique the a you're turning him and
I'm going to end up pull me in that
corner boom so I'm not pulling a darn
I'm not one is armed out I just have
this arm inch in Sheba not yet but I'm
doing the arms you're relevant to the
throat a butt for levity to chat okay
same thing here the way that you need
you to see that cross lateral tract
right you need to feel the height check
you need to understand that you're in
the back it looks you can when you when
you emphasize the grip like your ear
over here you're like gonna get the grip
of she hold on you see how I stopped
movie Hey
so you deprioritized everything else and
you're gonna get big big big grip and
then so you could throw it you want to
prioritize that placement oh if I don't
have the grip
we'll have everything else do you
understand that so find the grip at the
end and don't care about it grip is
low-percentage
every single time I know what you're
throwing you can feel them challenging
your grip but you never go hmmm that
probably won't work
do you understand me what's being
challenged in the dojo it's gonna fail
in the street okay so what I'm what I'm
doing instead is I'm blending with this
grip I move my body you guys use your
grip to do everything else so I have my
grip and I move my body so grips not
challenged so I can end up on this pin
here
all right again which one so so come
closer so you can see what I'm doing so
I'm doing all this to his body I'm
understanding that okay but my grip this
this is not the sort okay
I used the sword Gryff but I don't make
that a sword okay the sword was in my
hands do you remember
okay so here I'm just checking right so
if you look and I lose this grip or he
lets go that grip then I have the check
to the outside so imma being the rule of
angled deflection angle deviation right
synchronization so I'm to the right and
the angle deflection is going towards
the left you guys see that no I'm not
gonna go ahead and give him this so he
can do all the cooking doggies that I've
been training in so it's just a check
just to check at this point and I am
prioritizing everything else that I just
said and then I find it still right not
yet because I'm prioritizing the ADB
angle it's at this point that I start to
close and we have you stand up straight
coming and I have my kind of young
killed grip at the top here and then the
pinky that's where my sword grip goes
and boom to add to what I had do you
guys see that not to be all I have to
add to the EDB angle so this is going
this way this way this way okay
so check wool finishes that angle
[Music]
you will inhibit that if you grab her
you you won't be able to do it you're
gonna get on its forearms right and he
has leverage over me no matter what I do
he could be back like that because I
can't do this to his big forearm muscle
I could do it on his wrist but I can't
do it on his forearm muscle because
there's no hinge there that the hinge is
over here and it's connected to bigger
muscles that he has and you're not going
to get it but when you're over here you
can get it
so don't prematurely grab and you tend
to not prematurely grab if you rip to
slightly everything else you get it okay
you might think as a forward roll is an
acceleration outside his base of support
and so he has to roll or get his head
that's not it
you create an angle right and then you
can project through that you move his
entire line of gravity in a different
direction then his base of support is
going an acceleration is his line of
gravity and his base of support are
traveling in the same direction but the
line of gravity is traveling faster okay
that is entirely based upon his
athleticism if he's athletic enough he
will be able to get his base of support
under him or if he's skilled enough
he'll be able to roll with that he turns
that whole process upside down and now
he can't accelerate me okay so the
example is the one I just gave so here I
go I'm gonna do nimi Naga and I'm going
to basically have this kind of
acceleration you see and if you got leg
enough you can get back on
so the same thing here which means I'm
gonna make everything go that way by
entry angle school in that way hold on
so we don't want to accelerate him we
just want to deconstruct his posture so
his line of gravity goes one way his
space is support goes the other way
so if he holds on and we do the same
thing right
OOP there's no face you see that there's
note there's no residual momentum I got
a deal with in he because he held on you
can ends up right where my strikes are
so it doesn't change in sheet on
knocking I'm here I see beginners go
this route because this this
base-displacement requires base
replacement which requires base
integrity and you know how base
integrity there you go that's too much
so you go this easy way very much like
this cut something when people want to
go cross that will check on the elbow
they go wait over here so they take the
distal end of the lever you understand
and it's lighter but the checks not
there the checks goofy so same thing
here they're like I'm going to go in the
direction of his head Guinea Jane if
he's athletic you can run out of it
if he's school he'll just reverse it in
the end so when you're here it's the
deme angle it's the same EDB angle you
deconstruct his base boom so there's
none of that rotation Hey